still mad about how Game of Thrones went
down fear not House of the Dragon has
got your back keep watching to find out
why you should give it a shot Game of
Thrones took a heavy hit following the
release of its eighth season the show's
final episodes were penned by fans many
of whom criticized the story's rushed
pacing and many attempts to subvert
audiences expectations so what went
wrong well for one thing the white
walkers were defeated in one episode
after eight seasons of build up and if
you thought the night King stared down
with Jon Snow in season 5's hard home
guaranteed an epic final fight between
the two well think again Arya Stark is
the one to take out the night King in
the show while Jon is preoccupied with
the undead dragon viserion but that's
not all the Revelation that Jon is
actually aegon Targaryen trueborn son of
rhaegar Targaryen and lyanna Stark
ultimately leads to nothing Jon never
ascends the Iron Throne or fulfills the
prophecy of the prince that was promised
meanwhile Daenerys Targaryen flips from
Misa to Mad Queen in one harrowing
episode which sees her Slaughter the
civilians of King's Landing with
Dragonfire oh and Jaime Lannister
abandons Brienne of Tarth to die with
his sister and lover Cersei in the end
Bran Stark emerges From the Ashes as the
new king of Westeros because reasons and
who has a better story
than bran the broken naturally all of
this led many Game of Thrones fans to
vow that they were finished with the
once esteemed fantasy franchise
so far only one aspect of the Game of
Thrones finale has been confirmed to
come from Martin himself King bran
during a 2019 interview published by HBO
actor Isaac Hempstead writes stated
David benioff and Dan Weiss told me
there were two things George R.R Martin
had planned for bran and that was the
Hodor Revelation and that he would be
king so that's pretty special to be
directly involved in something that is
part of George's Vision unless Martin
changes his mind fans can't expect to
see bran on the throne in the books as
well as in the show everything else
however that remains questionable Martin
has even said that fans know unending
but not the ending it's certainly easy
for fans to remain hopeful for a more
satisfying conclusion to the novels
fortunately House of the Dragon seems to
be rebuilding Bridges with its spurned
audience a prequel to Game of Thrones
House of the Dragon takes place 172
years before Daenerys targaryen's birth
and documents one of the most turbulent
times in her family's history the period
of civil war known as the dance of the
dragons for fans who loved the political
drama and Scandals of Game of Thrones
this is the perfect successor show to
scratch that itch during its Premiere
episode House of the Dragon places as
much emphasis on the Song of Ice and
Fire as it does Game of Thrones in Heirs
of the Dragon King viserys informs his
daughter rhaenyra about a prophetic
dream of their ancestor aegons that
spurred him to conquer Westeros with his
Dragon Valerian the black dread aegon
called his dream The Song of Ice and
Fire King viserys passes on aegon's
vision of a terrible winter gusting out
of the distant North which prompted the
Conqueror to create the iron throne and
unify the kingdoms under Targaryen rule
it's an interesting tidbit that further
fleshes out the story of the others but
why did the showrunners Ryan condle and
Miguel sapochnik choose to include a
prophecy about the white walkers in a
show about House Targaryen particularly
in its first episode
as it turns out aegon the conqueror's
prophecy comes from none other than
George R.R Martin the author confirmed
his involvement with House of the Dragon
early on while showrunner Ryan Condell
spoke to Esquire about collaborating
with Martin he said George hired me and
I came to this as a fan he was very
involved with the beginning of the show
obviously it does not exist without him
he wrote the original Source material
condole continued this was the successor
show that I think he was most interested
in of all the ones that HBO was
considering and exploring certainly in
the very beginning in the conceptual
phase George was very involved in an
interview with the New York Times Martin
compared his involvement with House of
the Dragon to Game of Thrones remarking
how he was kept out of the loop during
the later seasons of Thrones he claimed
by season 5 and 6 and certainly seven
and eight I was pretty much out of the
loop I don't know why you have to ask
showrunners Dan and Dave with Martin at
the helm House of the Dragon offers the
chance to tell a story more faithful to
the author's original vision
thanks to George R Martin's involvement
House of the Dragon seems to be Bridging
the Gap between show and book Canon for
example aegon's prophecy makes no
mention of anything to symbolize Arya
Stark as the savior of humanity end the
last Scions of House Targaryen don't
really phase the night King in Game of
Thrones as Daenerys and drogon quickly
discover the icy villain is fireproof
while Jon is overwhelmed by Undead
soldiers before he can take a swing at
any white walkers it's certainly
possible that aegon's prophecy in House
of the Dragon isn't supposed to
foreshadow The Game of Thrones finale in
2019 before season 8 aired Martin
revealed to Entertainment Weekly that he
hadn't read any scripts for The Final
Season stating there's a lot of minor
character arcs they'll be coming up with
on their own and of course they passed
me several years ago there may be
important discrepancies more recently
Martin confirmed on his blog that his
ending will be different adding not all
of the characters who survived until the
end of game of drones will survive until
the end of A Song of Ice and Fire and
not all of the characters who died on
Game of Thrones will die in A Song of
Ice and Fire before House of the Dragon
HBO almost greenlit another prequel to
follow season 8 of Game of Thrones the
planned series titled blood moon was to
take place 8 000 years before the events
of the original show Jurgen era known as
The Age of Heroes what was blood moon
about in summary the white walkers this
prequel would have depicted the first
long night eight centuries before the
night King's defeat at Winterfell with
the white walkers descending on Humanity
from the far north for the very first
time according to HBO blood moon was
going to be seriously epic in scope the
first press release stated from the
horrifying secrets of westeros's History
to the true origin of the white walkers
the mysteries of the East to the Starks
of Legend it's not the story we think we
know Jane Goldman was to serve as
showrunner alongside George RR Martin as
an executive producer while Naomi Watts
had been cast in the lead role sadly
blood moon never made it past production
a pilot episode was filmed but the
series was shelved in favor of House of
the Dragon given that blood moon was
supposed to focus on the long night and
the origin of the white walkers it's
possible that aegon's prophecy or
whatever inspired it would have been
heavily involved in that series
it's worth noting that HBO doesn't
necessarily need blood moon to redeem
the series finale along with a slate of
prequel shows George R Martin confirmed
on his blog that a sequel to Game of
Thrones is currently in the pipeworks
not much is known so far but the sequel
but what fans do know is that the
planned series is Jon Snow Centric with
actor kit Harrington leading the project
You Know Nothing Jon Snow official news
of the Jon Snow sequel first broke in a
piece for The Hollywood Reporter Emilia
Clark later verified in an interview
with the BBC that Harrington essentially
created the show and that he is in it
from the ground up there are no
guarantees that the Jon Snow sequel will
make it out of pre-production still if
the series does make it to the small
screen it could retcon parts of season
8. it might even correspond with aegon's
prophecy in House of the Dragon a sequel
starring Jon Snow AKA aegon Targaryen
could very well feature the return of
the white walkers led by a new icy
villain for him to face
Game of Thrones could also be brought
back to the small screen in animation
according to George R Martin's blog an
animated prequel set in the distant land
of essos is also in the early stages of
pre-production the Golden Empire of vidi
inspired by Imperial China predates both
old valyria and the long night some fans
speculate that it was the gemstone
Emperors of Yeti who taught the
valyrians how to control dragons Corliss
valarian made the long perilous Voyage
to yidi in his youth something that
viewers could witness if his prequel
series is greenlit if HBO branches into
animation with its Yeti series then it's
also possible fans could see an animated
adaptation of A Song of Ice and Fire in
the future animation requires a less
Hefty budget too something that might
appeal to HBO after it spent 90 million
dollars on the final season of Game of
Thrones this is one way that Thrones
could return bigger and bloodier than
ever
the inclusion of aegon's Prophecy 2
House of the Dragon doesn't appear to be
a fluke a weeks ahead trailer released
on the official Game of Thrones YouTube
channel has teased even more prophecies
in the show in the teaser Millie
alcock's raniera Targaryen appears to be
reading more of aegon the conqueror's
documented prophetic dreams as she
States from my blood
[Music]
come the prince that was promised this
is big news for readers of the books in
the second novel a Clash of Kings
Daenerys Ventures into the house of the
undying to seek counsel from the
mysterious warlocks of karth Daenerys
consumes a psychedelic substance known
as shade of the evening and experiences
multiple prophetic Visions in one a
brutalized woman represents war-torn
Westeros another features the wolf King
at a feast foreshadowing the Red Wedding
several others include Snippets from the
past and the future of Martin's world
one such moment includes her brother
rhaegar talking with an unknown woman
about their newborn son during the scene
rhaegar speaks the same words that
rhaenyra speaks in the house of the
Dragon trailer it seems that house of
the Dragon will be tackling this crucial
plot thread sometime in the future
despite the fact that it apparently has
little to do with the main events of the
show with the runway success of House of
the Dragon the future of the Game of
Thrones franchise suddenly looks more
optimistic George R Martin's enthusiasm
for the prequel is gradually encouraging
fans trust again after the disastrous
final season of Game of Thrones and the
extra efforts taken to adhere to
Buchanan aren't exactly hurting either
HBO seems to be focusing on filling out
the world too with various prequels and
spin-offs set in Westeros and essos
lined up if any of them matched the
early success of House of the Dragon
then it's likely the streaming Titan
will go all in on building a potential
Martin Cinematic Universe if that
happens then revisiting the apocalyptic
threat from the far north sounds far too
good a spectacle to pass on whether it's
down to a Jon Snow sequel another
prequel or simply a plot thread followed
by a house of the Dragon there's a good
chance that the events of the final
season of Game of Thrones will one day
feel like nothing more than a bad dream
[Music]